[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans élémentaire
l'émission de Public Sénat qui cherche à
donner de la profondeur de champ aux
éléments de l'actualité les
manifestations des agriculteurs
auxquelles nous assistons depuis
quelques jours sont-elles l'une de ces
nombreuses secousses que connaît le
monde rural depuis euh les jacris
paysanes du Moyen-Âge ou bien est-ce le
champ du signe d'un système agricole
bâti par le général de Gaulle à la fin
des années 60 euh et qui est en train de
disparaître la France cessant d'être une
grande puissance agricole la population
paysane disparaissant comme pot de
chagrin et les fermes devenant des
firmes en tout cas la révolte suscite
une grande émotion et d'ailleurs de mon
point de vue légitime parce que euh non
seulement les paysans sont les
jardiniers de notre paysage et les
gardiens du vivant mais ils sont aussi
le lien qui nous relie à l'histoire
millénaire de notre
pays au-delà de l'émotion quels sont les
ressorts de cette crise quelles sont ces
causes comment peut-on en sortir sujet
éminemment complexe mais que nous allons
essayer de traiter simplement dans cette
émission que nous avons intitulé en
empruntant ce nom à un livre célèbre
d'Henry mras la fin des paysans avec
point un point d'interrogation et pour
nous aider dans cette tâche deux experts
Marion Guillou bonsoir ancienne PDG de
linra linra c'est le grand institut de
recherche
agronomique le deuxè institut du du
monde par le nombre de ses publication
scientifique vous êtes aussi membre du
Haut Conseil du climat et vous êtes
surtout présidente de l'Académie
d'agriculture qui existe depuis
1761 Vincent châelier bonsoir vous êtes
chercheur en économie et vous présidez
la Société Française d'Économie
rurale nous allons si vous voulez bien
essayer d'éclairer le sujet sous deux
angles d'abord en essayant de
d'identifier les nœuds Gordiens dans
lesquels paraî s s'enfermer
l'agriculture française et ensuite en
essayant de voir comment on peut
trancher ces nœuds si c'est possible il
me semble qu'il y a trois dilemmes si on
simplifie le premier le premier nœud
gordien Vincent c'est le libre échange
d'un côté et le maintien de l'agric ure
de l'autre est-ce qu'on peut
sérieusement imaginer de maintenir notre
système agricole tel qu'il est compte
tenu des contraintes qui pèsent sur lui
des contraintes de diversité mais même
des contraintes de notre modèle social
dans dans un marché ouvert et
compétitif il y a deux niveaux dans la
réponse il y a d'abord le niveau mondial
c'est-à-dire la connexion de l'Union
européenne au monde et il y a aussi le
libre échange à l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne donc c'est deux dossiers
différents sur le premier dossier donc
la relation de l'Union européenne aux
autres pays du monde cette relation
finalement elle est pas si mauvaise que
ce qu'on entend partout aujourd'hui la
balance commerciale de l'Union
Européenne à 27 le Royaume-Uni est en
sorti elle est de 30 milliards d'euros
il n'y a qu'un seul pays dans le monde
qui fait mieux que l'Union européenne
c'est le Brésil 60 milliards d'euros et
donc cette situation de balance
commerciale elle s'est nettement
améliorée contrairement à ce qu'on peut
entendre nous étions à 10 milliards il y
a en 2010 nous sommes à 30 milliards
donc l'Europe n'est pas attaquée par le
libre échange même s'il y a des dossiers
très sensibles elle en profite
elle en profite dans un certain nombre
de productions pas tous alors il y a des
productions elle est très forte
lesquelles les productions animales 50
milliards d'euros de balance commerciale
positif en production animal 30 pour le
lait 13 pour la viande porsine et deux
ou trois même pour la fili volail qui
est attaqué par ailleurs donc on a une
dynamique de commerce objectivement et
sur le commerce satisfaisant et sur le
commerce intraeuropéen alors là les
choses se gâtent beaucoup pour la France
et c'est pour ça que on parle d'un libre
échange mais c'est le libre échange
intérieur qui pose problème en fait la
balance commerciale de la France avec
les autres pays européens les 26 du coup
elle est de 1,8 milliard d'euros
négative aujourd'hui et en fait on a
dégradé cette balance commerciale avec
la plupart des pays européens dont deux
ou trois qui nous font un peu plus de
mal depuis quelques temps
l'Espagne la Pologne et bien sûr un pays
très très commerçant qui a la meilleure
balance commerciale agricole d'Europe
qui est les Pays-Bas et en fait la la ce
qu'on a quand on parle du libre échange
on parle beaucoup plus de l'intérieur de
l'Europe qui est une vieille question
qui a plus de 60 ans que du commerce à à
l'extérieur même si même si la question
du Mercosur est très est très sensible
et qu'on peut comprendre que le monde
agricole européen ne signe pas le
mercosour c'est le Mercosur c'est le
Brésil l'Argentine l'Uruguay et le
Paraguay c'est une zone commerciale avec
laquelle l'Europe a une balance négative
de 25 milliards d'euros c'est la la zone
du monde avec lequelle on est le plus
déficitaire on va revenir tout à l'heure
à la façon dont on peut répondre à ce
dilme mais donc pas vraiment de Dilemme
sauf la question du mercosour dans le
commerce mondial un vrai sujet sur le
commerce intrauropéen deuxème nœud
gordien ou le deuxième dilemme Marion
c'est la la compatibilité entre le souci
de l'environnement et de la santé de la
protection de l'air de la protection des
sols de la protection de l'eau de la
protection contre l'utilisation des
produits chimiques pour notre notre
bien-être ce souci d'un côté et celui de
l'autre côté de du développement
compétitif de l'agriculture française
est-ce que ces deux objectifs ne sont
pas
antinomique alors c'est ces deux
objectifs sont une réalité he il y a une
demande pour les deux alors évidemment
ce sont des réalités pas faciles à
rendre compatible mais dans un pays ou
dans une zone du monde comme l'Europe ou
dans un pays comme la France où les gens
ont envie d'être en bonne santé d'avoir
un environnement agréable de conserver
de la biodiversité de lutter contre le
changement climatique il est difficile
de ne pas conserver des objectifs
environnementaux et en même temps ne pas
être compétitif c'est condamner un
secteur c'est condamner de l'emploi
c'est condamner de l'activité donc je
pense qu'il faut de toute façon essayer
de tenir ces deux objectifs même si ça
suppose un tas de un tas de difficultés
un tas d'incompréhension descstruction
compliquée et euh sans doute des outils
plus imaginatifs parfois que ceux qu'on
a aujourd'hui parce qu'on a beaucoup on
a beaucoup attaqué et c'est le principal
instrument de de la la la poursuite de
ces deux objectif en même temps les
normes il y a une énorme revendication
des agriculteurs sur le fait qu'on les
assomme sous des normes qui rendent leur
vie impossible non compétitive
économiquement et horrible
administrativement
oui et en se mettant à la place d'un
agriculteur s'il a 70 je crois que c'est
à peu près 70 75 directiv à appliquer
dans son exploitation on comprend que ce
soit vraiment
assomant les les pays ont trouvé des des
solutions diverses je crois qu'en
Espagne en fait vous avez une gratuite
pour vous aider à remplir les les
formulaires en fait le sujet c'est de
pas trop en rajouter oui on demande aux
agriculteurs par exemple de couvrir leur
sol en hiver ça évite l'érosion c'est
bon pour le stockage de carbone ça
ajoutera de la matière organique
lorsqu'on enfouillera l'herbe donc c'est
plein de bénéfices environnementaux on
peut par des contrôles aériens vérifier
que ça a été fait ou pas fait et bien
qu'on le fasse par des contrôles aériens
qu'on simplifie partout où c'est
possible essayer de simplifier le la
déclaration et la vérification mais
est-ce qu'il y a pas une sur tout le
monde parle d'une surnormalisation
Française que d'autres pays poursuivrait
comme nous la compatibilité de ces deux
objectifs santé environnement d'un côté
agriculture de l'autre mais que nous
nous serions plus royalistes que le roi
sous la pression d'une partie de nos
secteurs d'opinion alors écoutez j'ai
j'ai il se trouve que j'ai habité dans
d'autres pays dans lesquel ils disent
exactement la même chose c'est il
prétendaiit qu'en France les gens
n'appliquaient pas les normes et que
chez eux leur administration était
beaucoup plus sévère bon donc il est un
peu normal d'être quand on est on a des
imprimés à remplir et que c'est ass
sommement de considérer qu'on est les
seuls à faire je crois pas que ce soit
vrai qu'on soit les seuls à faire en
revanche il arrive que pour des raisons
de discussion avec d'autres parties
prenantes ou des décisions politiques on
est ce qu'on appelle surtransposé
c'est-à-dire demander plus que ce qui
avait marqué dans la directive
communautaire alors il y a déjà un bon
remède qui est de faire des règlements
communautaires au lieu de faire des
directives à ce des textes directement
applic pas besoin de transposer on pas
besoin de les transposer c'est
directement applicable c'est le même
texte qui s'applique à travers toute
l'Europe donc ça déjà c'est une
simplification potentielle pour les gens
qui ont sur destinataire c'està-dire
infin les agriculteurs mais vous vous
considérer malgré les la plainte des
agriculteurs que nous n'avons pas
d'autres chos on va revenir tout à
l'heureau fond mais bien sûr qu'on a oui
objectivement je pense qu'on a d'autres
choix et notamment si on avait une
obsession chaque fois qu'on prend un
texte de vérifier si on n pas en
contradiction avec un autre si on peut
pas l'inclure dans un autre si on peut
pas les on a parlé de 14 textes sur les
je ne sais pas si c'est vrai ou pas mais
mais si c'est vrai c'est absurde donc
comment faire en sorte pour qu'on fasse
se rencontrer les exigences
réglementaires et qu'on simplifie pour
le destinataire final qui a le qui a le
texte à remplir oui je crois que c'est
une une vraie préoccupation 3è dilemme
3è incompatibilité Vincent le pouvoir
d'achat des Français d'un côté qui
suppose qu'on baisse les prix et le
revenu des agriculteurs de l'autre qui
évidemment suppose que les prix des
matières qu'ils vendent soient les plus
élevés possibles parce qu'aujourd'hui
ils disent que dans certain nombre de
cas le le coût de leurs
des entrant enfin leurs coût de
production sont supérieurs à leur prix
de vente comment est-ce qu'on rend
compatible cet objectif de désinflation
ou d'amélioration du pouvoir d'achat des
consommateurs et de préservation du
revenu des paysans bon d'abord on a fait
un travail nous pour le ministère de
l'agriculture sur les revenus dans
l'agriculture française et il y a deux
éléments principaux à sortir le premier
c'est qu'entre 2020 et 2022 il n'y a pas
eu d'effondrement des revenus de
l'agriculture française ramené à l'actif
agricole familial même si on aurait
tendance pour plaire un peu en ce moment
de dire que c'est le cas ça n'est pas le
cas les revenus sont meilleurs sur les
trois dernières années que sur la
période
2010-29 deuxè chose c'est pour ça qu'il
y a une révolte justifiée hein c'est que
les agriculteurs derrière des
agriculteurs il y a une hétérogénéité
des niveaux de revenu qui en dépit de la
très forte restructuration des
exploitations ne s'est pas gommé au fil
du temps donc on a autant de riches et
de pauvre aujourd'hui qu'avant donc sur
ces revenus la question c'est évidemment
de les maintenir parce qu'il y a besoin
de renouveler beaucoup d'agriculteurs et
donc si les revenus sont bas on
n'arrivera pas à procéder aux
investissements qui intègrent la
dimension environnement qu'on qu'on
évoquait tout à l'heure et c'est pour ça
que les agriculteurs sentent un très
grand malaise alors sur la question des
prix à la consommation je vous arrête
une seconde parce que j'ai en effet
regardez votre étude en effet le revenu
moyen des agriculteurs est à peu près
celui du revenu moyen médian pardon est
à peu près celui celui qui coupe en deux
la population est à peu près celui de la
population de non agricole en revanche
il a une dispersion des plus riches au
moins riches du des 10 % des plus riches
10 % les moins riches qui est beaucoup
plus forte et cette dispersion varie en
fonction soit de la taille en c'est
d'ailleurs ça peut être cumulatif soit
de la taille de l'exploitation soit des
du type de produit qu'ils font donc en
effet satistiquement ça ça c'est pas mal
en moyenne ou en médiane mais dans la
réalité la dispersion est telle qu'il y
a vraiment une situation difficile pour
beaucoup d'agriculteurs on estime qu'il
y a 20 % des agriculteurs qui sont sous
le seuil de pauvreté en France donc on
peut pas être trop fier de cette
situation surtout que ça dure depuis des
décennies c'estàd il y a toujours eu des
agriculteurs en difficulté des
agriculteurs dans dans avec des
situations économiques peu favorables ce
qu'on aurait pu espérer c'est qu'après
tant de restructuration qu'on est
finalement sélectionné les bons les
derniers et là on se rend compte qu'il y
a encore c'est encore ce problème en
2024 et donc la colère elle est grande
parce Queen fait les les doutes des
agriculteurs pour l'avenir augmentent et
ils augmentent en lien avec ce que vous
évoqueiez la question des prix et
évidemment que les
prix la question centrale je pense que
les lois les fameuses lois égalim qui
perd permettre finalement d'intégrer le
coût de production d'une exploitation
dans la dans la détermination du prix de
final vendu dans les grands magasins ou
autre c'est une bonne loi bon elle a été
rénovée he c'est la deuxième fois
maintenant il faut qu'elle rentre en
application donc l'ambition à mon avis
he pour la France c'est pas d'avoir une
succession de changement de loi tous les
2 ans c'est d'être capable d'appliquer
les lois sérieusement et et d'en
débattre au sein de la chaîne
d'approvisionnement parce que la grande
distribution aura besoin des agriculteur
demain pour gagner sa vie si elle croit
qu'elle gagnera plus en important moi en
tant qu'économiste je pense que c'est
faux parce que les importations
coûteront plus cher vous me faites une
bonne transition pour la seconde partie
qui est vers où on va j'avais le
sentiment moi mais parce que je suis
ignard que depuis le grand dessin du
général de Gaulle qui a fantastiquement
réussi puisqu'il a organisé modernisé
transformé l' agriculture française
pendant 30 à 40 ans le grand dessin du
général de goule il y a plus de grande
vision stratégique où il y a plus de
grande vision stratégique pour notre
agriculture mais peut-être que je me
trompe mais en dehors des visions
stratégiques je me demandais si si on
reprend les points qu'on a évoqué
ensemble il y avait des solutions qui
n'étaient pas mises en œuvre je je vais
essayer de les reprendre et de vous
interroger dessus donc la baisse des
normes Marion donc on vous l'avez évoqué
au-delà de la baisse des normes on a vu
sur les OGM ou sur le glyphosate que on
avait parfois nous les français une
vision très très comment dirais-je
conservatrice enfin un principe de
précaution que d'autres ne partageaient
pas et on voit par exemple que se
développe en Amérique latine des les OGM
et qui nourrissent le renouveau d'une
agriculture est-ce qu'on a est-ce qu'on
est est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir une une
une un chemin de transition écologique
tout à fait naturelle qui soit plus
modernisateur plus
technologique moins normatif et qui
peut-être accompagne mieux fus par des
subventions la transition agricole vers
une agriculture plus respectueuse du
climat oui oui c'est c'est toujours on a
toujours un dilème pour faire une
transition de toute façon c'est
difficile de faire une transition
puisqu'on change ses habitudes donc on
arrive vers l'incertain donc bah les
professionnels hésitent toujours à aller
vers l'incertain donc il faut essayer
d'aider collectivement cette transition
si elle est collectivement souhaitable
en les accompagnant par du conseil en
les incite
le cas échéant en faisant des
réglementations pour obliger mais c'est
toujours mieux d'avoir un mouvement qui
accompagne plutôt qu'un mouvement qui
contraint et donc lorsqu'on parle de
climat par exemple l'agriculture a une
chance d'une certaine manière qui est
très peu exploitée encore mais qui
pourrait l'aidere demain qui est le fait
que la terre le sol stock du carbone et
que certaines pratiques agricoles et on
en peut en faire la liste assez
facilement permettent de stocker plus de
carbone bon un temps alors certaines
momentanément puis il faut veiller à ce
que ce soit un stock de longue durée je
vous attends une seconde pour expliquer
ceux qui nous écoutent on peut réduire
nos nos émissions de carbone d'un côté
mais on peut aussi retenir le carbone
c'est les deux façons d'améliorer notre
notre enfin de de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et en effet la
terre stock du carbone donc ce que vous
dites c'est qu'on pourrait stocker
davantage de carbone oui surtout
qu'actuelle enfin depuis plusieurs
années on a tendance à déstockquer le
carbone vous savez c'est on a parlé du
Labour le labour Déstock le carbone
enfin un certain nombre de pratiqu on
conduit à enlever du carbone du sol et
par exemple le fait de ne pas laisser
les les herbes sur place qui vont
réenrichir les sols ou donc il y a eu un
certain nombre de pratiques qui de fait
ont conduit à appauvrir les sols en
carbone or le carbone a plusieurs
avantages et notamment bon l'avantage
d'abord de de capter du carbone et donc
de lutter contre les lesffet de serre
mais aussi de donner une meilleure
structure au sol de lui donner une plus
grande capacité de d'absorption d'eau or
on a besoin de stocker de l'eau au dans
les sols euh actuellement avec les
variations climatiques c'est utile de
savoir stocker plus d'eau dans les sols
donc c'est une pratique doublement
vertueuse vertueuse pour la société pour
l'environnement et vertueuse pour
l'agriculteur mais ça suppose un certain
nombre de travaux qui ne sont pas de
l'intérêt direct de l'agriculteur
immédiat ça ne lui rapporte rien dans
l'immédiat à terme ça peut enrichir sa
terre mais mais dans l'immédiat souvent
ça ne lui rapporte rien donc
collectivement il faudrait qu'on arrive
à mettre en place une rémunération non
pas par la contrainte mais une
incitation à stocker plus de carbone
dans les sols agricoles en lui donnant
une prix un prix une société qui
voudrait pouvoir continuer à avoir une
pratique qui aimet du carbone elle
pourrait acheter des crédits carbon à
des agriculteurs s'engagant à des
pratiques permettant de stocker du
carbone ça me conduit une seconde
question on a un niveau de subvention de
de concours public à l'agriculture
européenne et français élevé c'est 26
milliards d'euros si on prend tout en
compte c'est 1 % du PIB est-ce qu'on
est-ce qu' on peut pas mieux al je sais
bien que ça a été ça fait partie de la
réforme de la PAC mais est-ce qu'on peut
pas mieux orienter notre système d'ête
publique pour mieux accompagner d'un
côté les exploitations qui sont qui
souffrent le plus soit en revenu soit
pour se restructurer vers des des
productions plus faciles et puis d'autre
part mieux accompagner la transition
écologique est-ce qu'on a pas trop
sédimenter les aides est-ce qu'il y a
pas une façon de réinventer nos aides
pour qu'elles soi qu'elles accompagnent
mieux les obj objectif de à la fois
agricole et environnementaux alors c'est
toujours facile de faire Yaka faucon
mais disons que si tout ça suppose d'en
discuter d'abord avec les intéressés de
voir ce qui peut marcher mais oui il
serait souhaitable d'avoir par exemple
un accompagnement des éleveurs les
éleveurs vous le savez en France en
moyenne les seules choses qu' gagnent
enfin ils ne vendent ils vendent mais ça
ne fait qu'équilibrer leur coût donc
tout ce que gagne l'éleveur en moyenne
ça vient de subvention et et donc il
faut faire très attention quand on parle
de déplacer les subventions dans le
rapport du hautceil pour le climat
justement on on propose un certain
nombre d'évolution du système de
subvention et notamment en ciblant bah
ceux qui ont le plus de difficultés en
ciblant les pratiques qui vont permettre
ce meilleur stockage de carbone en
proposant des innovations en dans
l'élevage par exemple on peut ajouter
des choses à l'alimentation animale on
peut faire de la sélection génétique
pour que les animaux émettent ins de
méthane dans leur rau enfin je il y a un
certain nombre de pratiques d'élevage on
peut changer l'âge du village enfin ce
sont des choses qui peuvent pas se faire
du jour au lendemain mais il y a un
certain nombre de pratiques qui ont été
identifiées par les chercheurs de
l'inrae et qui permettrai de réduire de
30 % à peu près les émissions par animal
donc c'est pas négligeable quand un
ignorant comme moi regarde les
statistiques je je vois que des
productions qui sont très compétitives
notamment les les grandes productions
céréalières reçoivent des montants de
subvention conséquents
vous votre point de vue sur la la
réorientation des des aides publiques ou
un meilleur ciblage des aid pu c'est
toujours très compliqué parce qu' a
toujours des perdants et des gagnants
mais est-ce que c'est est-ce qu' est-ce
que on a modélisé ça est-ce qu'il y a
des moyens de faire mieux
alors on est nombreux à travailler avec
des collègues depuis 20 ans 25 ans à
chaque réforme de la PAC 92 99 2003 2008
2027 sur ces questions là c'est la
question n'est pas technique en fait les
outils existent on n jamais eu autant
d'outils pour orienter les aides de la
PAC donc c'est pas un déficit de de
comment dire d'imagination de l'appareil
administratif européen non au contraire
jamais on a eu autant de latitude dans
le cadre du plan stratégique national
donc le plan stratégique c'est la
possibilité qui est offerte aux
États-membres de choisir justement
comment ils vont orienter les aides et
la difficulté on l'a bien vu c'est que
la France bah elle ne veut pas se
pénaliser dans l'orientation des aides
par rapport à d'autres pays concurrents
donc en donnant de la latitude aux
États-membres on se rendre compte en
fait qu'ils deviennent frileux et
l'application de ce qu'on appelle
excusez-moi du terme technique mais ce
qu'on appelle l'échorégime c'est le fait
de conditionner 25 % des aides de la
politique agricole commune à des
comportements environnementaux et
climatiques ben en France on a tout fait
que pour que tout le monde a fait un
papier scientifique làdessus avec des
collègues on a tout fait pour que tout
le monde en bénéficie ça veut dire que
c'est pas du tout un problème de
d'outils disponiblebles c'est un
problème de de mise en cohérence à
l'échelle de l'Europe du Green Deal je
je vois bien la difficulté parce que
quand on a un système d'aide et qu'on
change de système d'aide bah on fait des
perdants et des gagnants et donc c'est
toujours très c'est un choix douloureux
mais en même temps on se dit enfin c'est
une question une fois encore naïve je
vous la pose à tous les deux qu'on
pourrait accompagner qu'on peut investir
entre guillemets pendant un certain
temps racheter les avantages si j'ose
dire accompagner cette transition des
aides pendant un certain temps pour pour
permettre d'avoir une une un système
d'aide qui serait plus conforme à nos
objectifs stratégiques euh les
agriculteurs sont déjà très dépendants
des aides prenez la production bovine
aujourd'hui on est à 200 % d'aide dans
le revenu donc la question c'est pas de
leur REM en moyenne c'est 70 % en
moyenne 64 % sur les TR dernières années
les séraliers sont plutôt 80 donc il y a
des production notamment l'élevage
d'herbivor on est au-delà des 100 % oui
mais on a l'impression que ces aides ont
un effet conservateur et pas un objectif
de transformation euh c'est un terme que
que j'accepte volontiers madame la
Présidente euh oui le sujet c'est
effectivement la compétition je vous
donne un exemple paradoxal donc en mai
euh c'était 2022 je crois on cherche à
aider l'Ukraine l'Ukraine ne peut plus
exporter par la mer Noire donc l'Europe
veut créer des couloirs pour que les
produits agricoles ukrainiens
puissent'exporter et que les Ukrainiens
les notamment l'agriculture ukrainienne
puisse continuer à vivre mais le
problème c'est que normalement c'était
pour être exporté en pratique il y a pas
mal de produits qui sont restés d'abord
dans les pays limitrophes puis après des
des produits qui sont restés y compris
en France et actuellement je crois que
c'est sur les poulets on a des dizaines
de milliers de tonnes de poulet qui
viennent d'Ukraine qui ne respectent pas
les normes de bien-être lors de
l'élevage qui ne respectent pas les
normes environnementales le coût du
travail est inférieur donc par rapport à
un éleveur en France ou en Europe qui
respecte toutes les normes européennes
évidemment il est beaucoup moins cher
mais dans la réalité c'est marginal je
crois que les les poulets je crois qu'on
a consommé cette année 350 g par
habitant européens un quart de poulet
ukrainien par habitant européen donc
c'est symb non non c'est pas marginal
sur le marché du poulet en ce moment sur
le marché de l'œuf en ce moment en
France oui c'est des dizaines de pour
c'est des dizaines de% donc ça pèse sur
les prix et et le consommateur français
notamment enfin quand il va au
supermarché souvent v il y a quand même
un étiquetage qui explique d'où ça vient
et comment ça a été élevé mais en
restauration hors foyer que ce soit dans
dans les cantines ou dans les
restaurants vous avez très peu
d'indications de la provenance de la
nourriture que vous mangez et donc ben
on a de plus en plus d'importations vous
savez que c'est 22 % en moyenne les
importations alimentaires en France dans
la restauration hor foyer c'est 50 %
donc ben un produit arrive moins cher il
y aura quand même une tendance à
l'utiliser un maximum je reviens à ma
question sur le conservatisme des des
des ultra enfin des des libéraux
pourrait dire moins de normes
environnementales plus plus de mécanisme
d'incitation mais moins de norme moins
d'aide ou en tout cas des aides mieux
orienté vers plus de compétitivité
n'essayons pas de maintenir toute la
diversité de notre agriculture essayons
de nous concentrer je sais bien que ces
projets ont quelque chose de son c'est
c'est les professeurs Nimbus mais moi je
dirais on a un système depuis 20 ans qui
donne beaucoup d'aide à l'hectare enfit
en fait on est détenteur d'hectare et on
a une aide à l'hectare on en est plus ou
moins sorti c'est-à-dire en terme de
diversité entre agriculteurs puisqu'on a
homogénéité le montant d'aide à
l'hectare mais ce qu'on a pas assez fait
c'est réorienter des aides vers la
dynamique de projet qu'elle soit de
nature environnementale ou qu'elle soit
de nature aussi productive les deux ne
sont pas opposés et en fait les jeunes
agriculteurs pourquoi est-ce qu'ils sont
si nombreux autour des routes
aujourd'hui parce que ils ont pas
beaucoup plus d'aide parce que les taux
d'intérêts sont passés de 1 % à 4 % donc
c'est beaucoup plus dur d'investir et
parce que en plus ils sont critiqués
donc ça fait beaucoup en ce moment donc
faut qu'on réajuste par rapport au
projet effectivement vous avez raison
par rapport au projet qu'on souhaite
mettre en œuvre un projet
environnemental mais aussi en France un
projet productif parce que il manque 17
% de volaille 10 % de viande bovine 40 %
de viande ovine on va bientôt on a perdu
1 milliard de litres de lait en l'espace
de 5 ans je veux dire la copie
productive de la France elle elle n'est
pas bonne mais c'est ça on a
l'impression qu'on per sur tous les
tableaux dernière question
malheureusement parce que le temps
bouscule mais la réduction de la du
libre échange intraeuropéen plus de
protectionnisme le souver souverainisme
agricole le regain du souverinisme
agricole ça vous paraît en quelques
secondes ça vous paraît une farfelue ou
où il y a une voie sur laquelle on peut
travailler à l'INT globalement quand on
regarde l'agriculture française avec un
petit peu plus de recul on a gagné à la
politique agricole commune la France a
gagné à être membre de l'Europe le
marché unique a été positif pour
l'agriculture et l'alimentation
française donc il faut toujours corriger
les défauts de marché à un moment ou un
autre il faut toujours corriger les
défauts la lourdeur ou la bureaucratie
mais globalement on a été gagnant de
cette mise en place de la politique
agricole commune et du Marché Commun
Vincent quelques secondes moi il y a
deux gros dossier important pour pour
l'Europe et la France c'est l'Ukraine
puisqueaujourd'hui l'Europe a une
balance commerciale négative de 10
milliards avec ce pays et c'est bien sûr
le mercosour où on peut comprendre le
monde agricole s'il ne souhaite pas
qu'il a desacords parce que ce pays est
très déséquilibré dans sa relation avec
l'Europe merci à vous deux merci cette
émission s'achève même si nous savons
nous sommes loin d'avoir épuisé le sujet
un sujet essentiel je vous lis quelques
lignes de Michelet dans le peuple la
passion du paysan français sa maîtresse
et la terre elle ne donnerait rien à
cette pauvre terre de France si elle
n'était pas aimée chez nous l'homme et
la terre se tiennent et ne se quitteront
pas il y a entre eux un légitime mariage
à la vie et à la
mort on comprend mieux l'émotion que
suscite en France la crise du monde
agricole merci Marion Guillou merci
Vincent châelier de nous avoir aidé non
pas à éclairer complètement le sujet
mais en tout cas à projeter sur lui
quelques éléments de compréhension vous
pouvez revoir cette émission sur le site
de publicsénat
publsenat.fr merci d'avoir écouter cette
émission de l'avoir suivi et nous nous
revoyons lors de la prochaine émission
de d'élémentaire merci à
vous